This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. I want you to conjure an image in your mind of the white stripes. Not those white stripes, but the white stripes that divide the lanes of traffic going in the same direction on a major highway. How long are those stripes? You can spread your arms out to estimate if you want to. Over the course of many years, a psychology researcher named Dennis Schaeffer at Ohio State asked students from many different parts of the country this question. And the most common response was two feet. So if you're like most people, you estimated that those white stripes are two feet long,
这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我想让你在脑海中想象一下白色标线。不是那种白色标线，而是主干道上划分同方向车道的白色标线。那些标线有多长？如果你愿意，可以把手臂张开来估测一下。多年来，俄亥俄州立大学的一位心理学研究员丹尼斯·谢弗向来自全国各地许多不同地方的学生提出了这个问题。最常见的回答是两英尺。所以，如果你和大多数人一样，你估计那些白色标线有两英尺长，
maybe a little more. But if you did, you'd be very, very wrong. This is Tom Vanderbilt. My name is Tom Vanderbilt. I'm a writer in New York and author of Traffic Why We Drive the Way We Do and What It Says About Us. Every three pages of Tom's terrific book traffic, I can probably turn into a 99% of his episode, but back to the highway. Well, early on in my research, I was talking to a highway engineer and he said, if your car is ever broken down on the side of the road,
也许稍微多一点。但如果你这么想，那就大错特错了。这位是汤姆·范德比尔特。我叫汤姆·范德比尔特。我是纽约的一名作家，著有《交通：我们为什么这样开车以及这说明了什么》。汤姆那本精彩的书《交通》里的每三页，我大概都能做成一期99%隐形的节目，不过我们还是回到高速公路上来。嗯，在我的研究早期，我曾与一位高速公路工程师交谈，他说，如果你的车在路边抛锚了，
we've ever been forced to get out of your vehicle on a highway. Just take a moment to notice what a strange landscape it is. If you're happy to be standing near a road sign, these road signs are huge. I mean, they're not meant to be experienced as humans on foot, they're meant to be experienced at 75 miles an hour.
如果你曾在高速公路上被迫下车。花点时间注意一下这是一个多么奇怪的景观。如果你刚好站在路标附近，这些路标非常巨大。我的意思是，它们不是让人类步行去体验的，而是让人在时速75英里下体验的。
With the clear view typeface. Perfectly visible, retro reflective. And then there are the white stripes. If you actually kind of got out of your car and were able to walk on a closed highway and walk from one end of those stripes to the other, you'd find that, I mean, years ago in the United States, the highway standard was fifteen feet long
采用清晰的视线字体。清晰可见，具有逆反射性。还有白色标线。如果你真的下车，能够走在封闭的高速公路上，从这些标线的一端走到另一端，你会发现，我的意思是，多年前在美国，高速公路的标准是15英尺长，
which is longer than car itself current federal highway administration guidelines suggest a length of ten feet with thirty feet between the dashes that's something that that is shocking to people and remember most people in the shape of study said that those stripes were two feet long that's such a vast
这比汽车本身还要长。目前联邦公路局的指南建议长度为10英尺，标线间距为30英尺。这让人感到震惊。记住，参与研究的大多数人都说那些标线是两英尺长。这真是一个巨大的
culture between it's not you know it's not sort of like said that those stripes were two feet long. That's such a vast gulf there between. It's not sort of like, they're actually five feet without they were two margin of error kind of thing. And it goes back to this fundamental point that when you're in a car at high speeds, you're experiencing only a sense of the landscape rather than the actual landscape. This kind of sense of landscape has been presented to you to essentially make you feel comfortable.
两者之间的差距。这并不是说，你知道，这不像他们说那些标线是两英尺长。两者之间存在着巨大的鸿沟。这并不像他们实际上是五英尺，而他们认为是两英尺那种误差。这追溯到一个根本点：当你在高速行驶的汽车中时，你体验到的只是对景观的感觉，而不是真实的景观。这种对景观的感觉被呈现给你，本质上是为了让你感到舒适。
And to make a highway work at what are really evolutionarily ridiculous speeds for a human to travel. You have this big, flat, wide open, kind of stretch of road that even if you have a 65-mph sign, the message of the road is telling you something entirely different. I think that's really where a lot of our behavior comes from. Sometimes you have sort of willful speeding, willful kind of law breaking,
并使高速公路在对人类来说实际上处于进化论上荒谬的速度下运转。你拥有宽阔、平坦、开阔的道路，即使你看到了限速65英里的标志，道路传达的信息也完全不同。我认为这正是我们许多行为的来源。有时你会看到某种故意的超速、故意的违法行为，
but a lot of it is just people are paying attention to the visual messaging of the road, not to their speedometer. Long dividing lines and clear vistas, give the illusion that you're going at a reasonable speed, as soon as something encroaches into view, you get a sense of how fast you're going. That's one reason why those temporary concrete walls that crews put up right next to the road during construction are so unnerving. The error in perception of white striped length
但很大程度上只是人们在关注道路的视觉信息，而不是他们的速度表。长长的分道线和开阔的视野给人一种你在以合理速度行驶的错觉，一旦有什么东西进入视野，你就会感觉到自己的行驶速度有多快。这就是为什么施工期间工人们放在路边紧挨着的那些临时混凝土墙让人如此心神不宁的原因之一。对白色标线长度的感知误差
is attributed to the fact that when we drive on the highway, we tend to look so far ahead that we usually only experience the dashes and gaps when they are very far away in an angle where they look shorter. But there's no consensus as to why people all over the country were so consistently wrong with the two-feet estimate. It's, yeah, become my favorite, one of my favorite cocktail party, you know, facts. Mine too. Stump the driver with this white stripes information. I don't want to leave you with the impression that the white dividing lines are uniform though.
归因于这样一个事实：当我们在高速公路上开车时，我们往往往前方看得很远，以至于我们通常只有在它们离得很远且处于让我们看起来更短的角度时，才会体验到标线和间隙。但是，对于为什么全国各地的人们在两英尺的估计上会如此一致地出错，目前还没有达成共识。这，是的，已经成为我最喜欢的，我最喜欢的鸡尾酒会话题之一，你知道的，事实。我也是。用这个白色标线的信息难倒司机。不过，我不想让你留下白色分道线是千篇一律的印象。
You won't find, you know, 10 foot highway lines on a, say, a boulevard in New York City. And you probably won't find 10 or 15 foot stripes on bridges or highway on ramps. Or let's hope you don't because that's an entirely inappropriate design language for that space. Limited access highways are designed for a very precise purpose. There's the highways meant for uninterrupted fast flowing traffic. Get people from point A to point B, it's quickly as possible with no interruptions. I mean that sort of environment does not work in cities or suburbs. The problem is when that approach is grafted into
你知道，你不会在纽约市的林荫大道上找到10英尺的高速公路标线。而且你可能也不会在桥梁或高速公路匝道上找到10英尺或15英尺的标线。或者我们希望你找不到，因为对于那个空间来说，这是一种完全不恰当的设计语言。受限出入高速公路是为非常精确的目的而设计的。高速公路旨在提供不间断的快速流畅交通。让人们以尽可能快的方式从A点到达B点，中间没有任何中断。我的意思是，这种环境在城市或郊区是行不通的。问题在于，当这种方法被嫁接到
places where it doesn't belong. I think we're actually kind of paying the price for this right now in some suburban environments where you find these kind of arterial highways that were built almost an engine highway engineering standard with again these long sightlines, wide roads encouraging people to go fast and then we went and built all kinds of development along those arterial highways which was never really supposed to be there but with so many people driving on these roads they became absolutely irresistible to commerce. This is kind of the new American Main Street, right, where you have your Costco's and your
不属于它的地方时。我认为我们现在实际上正在某些郊区环境中为此付出代价，在那里你会发现这种干线公路，它们几乎是按照高速公路工程标准建造的，同样具有长视线、宽道路，鼓励人们开快车，然后我们在这些干线公路沿线建造了各种各样的开发项目，这些项目本来就不应该在那里，但由于有这么多人开着车行驶在这些商业道路上，它们对商业产生了不可抗拒的吸引力。这有点像新的美国商业街，对吧，那里有你的Costco和你的
your fast food and all sorts of in and out parking lots, driveways, drive-throughs. Yet people also going very fast and kind of Eric Dumbaw does a lot of research suggesting that these are really some of the most dangerous places to currently drive in America, not crowded urban cities, which is what a lot of people would think. The whole approach is called the forgiving road. The idea was that, you know, to first try to minimize the potential that a crash could happen through, again, through lack of obstacles, you know, generous sightlines, all these sorts of things.
你的快餐以及各种各样进进出出的停车场、车道、免下车餐厅。然而人们的车速也非常快，埃里克·邓巴（Eric Dumbaugh）做的大量研究表明，这些实际上是目前美国驾驶最危险的一些地方，而不是拥挤的大城市，很多人会这么认为。这种方法被称为“宽容道路”。这个想法是，你知道，首先要通过消除障碍、慷慨的视线等各种方式，尽量减少发生车祸的可能性。
But then if crash did happen to kind of mitigate the effects of what would happen to not punish the driver for the mistake that he will inevitably make. This was I'm quoting some of the language from the time. So you see that nowadays in things like in California, you'll have your guardrails that are sort of wire guardrails that if car strikes that guardrail tends to catch on the guardrail rather than being bounced back out into traffic, which causes another series of collisions. So this forgiving road is a positive thing in terms of good safety engineering. But they were so sort of seduced by it that the call was made to bring it into
但如果真的发生车祸，可以减轻事件的后果，不因驾驶员不可避免的犯错而惩罚他。这是我当时引用的一些语言。所以你现在在加利福尼亚等地看到，你会看到一些钢丝护栏，如果汽车撞上这种护栏，它往往会挂在护栏上，而不是被弹回车流中，从而引发另一系列碰撞。因此，就良好的安全工程而言，这种宽容道路是一件积极的事情。但他们对其如此着迷，以至于决定将其引入
even the surface street network. So things like street trees began to be deemed hazards by engineers, just outright hazards. I mean, that makes sense on a high-speed country road, but if you're talking about residential street, we're not supposed to be going more than 25 anyway, is the presence of a street tree in the side of the road where it's providing shade
甚至表面街道网络。因此，诸如行道树之类的东西开始被工程师视为隐患，甚至是彻头彻尾的隐患。我的意思是，这在高速乡村公路上是有道理的，但如果你谈论的是限速无论如何不应该超过25英里的住宅区街道，路边的行道树能够为行人提供阴凉
and comfort to pedestrians, is that the same sort of hazard? Is it even a hazard at all? The conclusion many planners came to was, yes, trees are a hazard. You find pre-war suburbs, you have the street, a set of trees, and then the sidewalk. Coast war, this sort of shift began to happen
和舒适，这算是一种隐患吗？它根本算是隐患吗？许多规划师得出的结论是，是的，树木就是隐患。你在战前郊区会发现街道、一排树木，然后是人行道。战后，这种转变开始发生，
where the trees removed on the other side of the sidewalk. Suddenly pedestrians were put into the position of being the buffer between drivers and those menacing trees. There was sort of a pernicious thing that happened here is that, you know, as you move those trees away, the visual sensation of the road became wider. And if there's one kind of iron law of traffic engineering, it gets into this visual perception thing as well. The wider a road is or is perceived to be the faster driver speed tends to increase. And of course, you know, the final,
树木被移到了人行道的另一侧。突然之间，行人被迫成为驾驶员和那些来势汹汹的树木之间的缓冲。这里发生了一件有害的事情，你知道，当你把那些树木移开时，道路的视觉感变得更宽了。如果说交通工程学有一种铁律的话，它也涉及这种视觉感知的东西。道路越宽，或者人们认为道路越宽，驾驶员的车速往往就越快。当然，你知道，最后，
if you look at sort of 1990s era, you know, the suburbia that they just kind of eliminated the sidewalk and the trees altogether. So that was sort of the final solution, just to eliminate any kind of hazard. And Tom Vanderbilt says you can almost date a subdivisions development based on that shift. a subdivisions development based on that shift.
如果你看看20世纪90年代左右的郊区，你会发现他们干脆取消了人行道和树木。所以这就是终极解决方案，只是为了消除任何形式的隐患。汤姆·范德比尔特说，你几乎可以根据这种转变来确定一个分小区的开发时间。
This points to one of the problems about road engineering is that humans tend to consume the extra engineering measures that have been built in for their safety. Much in the same way I like to draw the analogy with some of the research that's been done on food packaging by Brian Wandsick at Cornell University. You're doing experiments where, you know, if you give people, just random group people, large buckets of popcorn filled to the top with popcorn and give them a smaller amount of popcorn in a smaller package, they'll just eat more of the larger package, whether they're,
这指出了道路工程存在的问题之一，即人类往往会消耗为他们的安全而内置的额外工程措施。这与我喜欢做的类比非常相似，康奈尔大学的布赖恩·万辛克（Brian Wansink）在食品包装方面做了一些研究。你正在做实验，如果你给人们，只是一群随机的人，装满爆米花的特大号爆米花桶，而在一个小包装里给他们少量的爆米花，他们只会吃掉大包装里更多的东西，不管他们是否，
it has nothing to do with their level of hunger. It's just the size of the package influences their behavior. And I think a lot of our road environments are sort of like that. They're over engineered for this safety. And then we tend to consume a lot of the extras, getting us back to this kind of homeostatic edge that we're always kind of playing with, I think. 99% Invisible is Sam Greenspan and me Roman Mars. It's a project of 91.7 local public radio, KALW in San Francisco, and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. happens as go. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook.
这与他们的饥饿程度无关。只是包装的大小影响了他们的行为。我认为我们的许多道路环境也是这样的。它们为了安全而被过度设计了。然后我们往往会消耗许多额外的东西，让我们回到这种我認為我們一直在把玩的这种稳态边缘。99%隐形节目制作人是萨姆·格林斯潘和我罗曼·马尔斯。它是旧金山91.7地方公共广播电台KALW以及旧金山美国建筑师学会的一个项目。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目。你可以找到这个节目并在Facebook上点赞。
In fact, that's where a lot of the discussion and interaction happens. So join us over on Facebook. We're getting pretty close to 10,000 likes, which I would really enjoy. I tweet at Roman Mars, and we have links to all the stuff that we've been talking about in this episode at 99%invisible.org. Oh, one more thing. I and every other creative audio lover owes a huge debt to the Third Coast International
事实上，很多讨论和互动都在那里发生。所以加入我们的Facebook吧。我们的点赞数快接近1万了，我真的很喜欢这样。我在推特上叫罗曼·马尔斯，我们在99percentinvisible.org上提供了本期节目中讨论的所有内容的链接。哦，还有一件事。我和其他所有热爱音频创作的人一样，对第三海岸国际
Audio Festival. And every year I send them a little something to make sure that they keep going or I buy a T-shirt and they have hands down my favorite T-shirt design in the whole world across the front is the word listen written in braille. I have like six of them in every color. It's a must-have for any radio lover. You can find out the various ways that you can support the Third Coast International Audio Festival at 3rd Coast Festival dot org. at 3rd Coast Festival. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
音频节（Third Coast International Audio Festival）充满感激。每年我都会送给他们一点心意，以确保他们能够继续办下去，或者我买一件T恤，他们拥有我心目中全世界最棒的T恤设计，正面写着盲文单词“听”。我有大约六件各种颜色的。这是任何广播爱好者的必备品。你可以在3rdCoastFestival.org上找到支持第三海岸国际音频节的各种方式。这期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。